Denise and Brian the man we spoke with
today doesn't know what else to do he
tells me he's out five thousand dollars
he hasn't seen his car in a year and he
can't get a hold of the mechanic who has
it
yeah I just want the car back after a
year of unanswered questions Aaron
schlefka is fed up I've left him with
numerous messages letters on the door he
says he took his car to this Henderson
mechanic to get a new engine last
November pay part of the money up front
but never got it back about three months
ago
uh just radio silence the doors are
locked now Aaron tells us the owner of
Dwayne's Automotive just won't call
won't come back
doesn't
appear just don't have time for this my
daughter lives with me with my grandson
we're a one vehicle family now so we are
and
it's no longer in service and while the
place appears to be unreachable we were
interrupted by Henderson Police saying
the owner had called them requesting we
stay off his property I don't expect the
car to be in any better condition than
when I dropped it off but I just want to
move on Aaron isn't sure where he can go
from here but he's willing to do do
anything I'm willing to settle up even I
was willing to pay him the money I owe
to get what belongs to him back I'm sure
to be a lot better in the end if he just
hands over property
now Aaron says he also filed a police
report trying to get his car back but
officers told him this is a civil
situation he even says though he doesn't
have his car he's still paying payments
on it Sasha Loftus 8 News Now